avis de tempête pour le septième art
entre les nombreux blockbusters qui ont
dû être repoussés et les espaces fermés
qui n'attire que pau les spectateurs en
période de pandémie
le cinéma n'attire plus autant pourtant
à trappes dans les yvelines
le cinéma le grenier à sel ne connaît
pas la crise
la situation des cinémas des salles de
cinéma est un peu compliquée en ce
moment
les films sont du mal à sortir en salles
puisque le marché mondial est bloqué la
moyenne nationale
est à - 70 % par rapport à l'année
précédente au grenier à sel on est un
cinéma qui fait évidemment jamais comme
les autres et nous on est
on est à + 11 % pour l'instant pour
continuer sur cette lancée le grenier à
sel a dû refaire sa programmation
on a fait une organisation peu
particulière cette année puisqu'on est
ouvert tout l'été
ça veut dire qu'il a fallu alléger les
séances aussi pour pouvoir aérer la
salle il faut aussi espacer les séances
donc on a moins de 6 ans que d'habitude
et pourtant le public familial vient le
public art et essai vient les adultes
viennent le cinéma suit donc
scrupuleusement les conditions
sanitaires
même si cela se fait ressentir dans le
nombre d'entrées au niveau des mesures
sanitaires ça n'a pas beaucoup changé
depuis l' ouverture c'est à dire que
dans le hall d'entrée dans les
circulations quand on se lève pour aller
aux toilettes et tout ça il faut avoir
un masque obligatoire
par contre une fois qu'on est assis on
peut enlever son masque une fois qu'on
est statique qu'on est assis dans les
son masque au niveau du placement
les groupes doivent laisser une place de
chaque côté pour les autres groupes
donc c'est un groupe de une personne
c'est un groupe de cinq personnes il
faut laisser les places sur les côtés
c'est aussi cela qui pose un problème
pour l'un pour les entrées nationales
c'est que ça réduit la jauge des salles
d'environ 40% et forcément ça fait des
entrées en moins pour continuer dans
cette bonne dynamique et ne pas perdre
de clients
la structure vieille de 500 ans a prévu
plusieurs avant premières
la prochaine est prévue le 4 septembre
avec en invité principal antoine de
maximy qui présentera son film j'irai
mourir dans les carpates